you're live or not i usually sing so i
have all the start of these streams
where i'm just kind of singing
um very strangely it looks like it's
still not live
i'm not sure why
come on bud come on buddy you can do it
i think it did it
i think it successfully did the thing
come on
[Music]
people are spamming f in chat because
it's slightly delayed
i think it worked though yeah we did it
pretty sure they're still spamming f
though so i'm not positive
no we're good okay hello everyone
uh i'm alana and i'm joined by
phil hornshaw from gamespot and tom
marks
from ign both of whom i know very well
um
the two of you got to play 16 hours of
cyberpunk i did not but i wanted to ask
you guys
questions about it um i i guess
first up how did they time 16 hours how
did they
make sure it was just two full work days
it was just
days and days in this game hell yeah it
was two full work days with like
i don't know probably the same thing
phil it was like like a scheduled
one-hour lunch in the middle
oh wow like it was yeah it was and and
we actually
the second day i i took a shorter lunch
and then they cut it off a little early
right so like it was
it was very scheduled 16 hours wow it
was like
going to an event but at home yeah
previews are real weird this year
um but i guess i wanted to ask with a
very broad question
to start with of can i just get like
obviously this is a preview
you this is not reviews the those seem
like we'll probably get them in the
coming weeks obviously
um i guess i'll start with you phil what
are your overall impressions of the 16
hours that you played
i had a good time i liked it i mean it's
you know it's a
cd project rpg it's huge and expansive
and has some cool writing and a lot of
different
gameplay systems i keep kind of liking
it to the deus ex
games because it that's what it feels
like except it's uh maybe this story is
a little deeper a little broader um with
all the stuff that you can kind of get
off to
well i feel like that's interesting
because so many people keep saying gta
and i keep trying to fight against that
from everything that i've played i'm
like it's not like gta
it's yeah right aside from it being an
open world that is la-esque
and you can grab cars off anybody on the
street sure that's about it
and cops will come i guess um but how
about you tom what are your your
impressions
no yeah i really enjoyed it as well like
i think it was a good sign at the end of
that first day where
it was like this nine hour day with a
scheduled lunch and playing eight hours
straight with a
pr person watching everything you do and
then at the end of the day i was like
i want to keep playing that game like i
definitely
i definitely want more and i want to go
back and there's again like
there are rough edges here and there and
it's not like a perfect game in the same
way
like the thing i'm worried about with
this game when it launches is like
people will think of the witcher 3 net
we'll be comparing it to the witcher 3
now
and forgetting that the witcher 3 at
launch was like pretty rough
right like i mean it was kind of rough
right and it definitely
looks like a tank but but at least right
now he doesn't have like
every crafting item in his inventory
doesn't take like weight
bags weight right like oh yeah the
inventory was terrible i modded that
before they updated it
yeah and like i'm not saying this is
like a disaster or anything
it's just like like i i don't think cdpr
makes
perfect games they make incredibly fun
cool games and this is a
very very cool fun game from what i've
seen so far so if you've thrown a
negative note in there
i can get into like some of the things
that that's okay some of the things you
guys don't like about it because the
two things that i wasn't super fond of
were
the main one was hand-to-hand combat um
i've not actually tried it but felt like
it didn't look great
uh everything that i've seen of it i've
been a little bit concerned about it and
i wasn't
totally sold on the driving mechanics
that they had at the time but i know
that they were actively updating those
so i guess to either of you have
impressions of either of those two
things
uh yeah i can speak to i messed with the
sword
for a bit and yeah it feels a little
flaily you know what i mean like you
just kind of spam it
in the general direction of a person and
hopefully
um i think you can get good at it which
is cool
um if you like
aim well you can like slice off limbs
and stuff but i never
got to that point your audio just got
really low i don't know what i
need to mess with but noted
thank you uh how about you tom did you
try
melee combat yeah the melee um
it felt like they they had these like
fist fight like a bare knuckle boxing
kind of side missions you can do
as well uh and it felt sort of like
basic but there was a little nuance
there i guess is the same thing where
you have like a light attack and a heavy
attack and then you can block and if you
time your block right
you do like a counter punch right so
there's like the basics of like a little
of a fun kind of melee system there but
i agree that in the heat of
kind of other things going on it felt a
little flaily um
at times but it also wasn't like
distractingly bad and
i guess the kind of way i would say it
is like it didn't seem
gone i guess he'll come back
it didn't seem bad in like it it was fun
enough
and it didn't seem bad it just seemed
bad in the way or like kind of subpar in
the way that like i'd rather be
using the guns and the other abilities
right right like it doesn't seem like
something i would want to spend my time
with
exactly kind of what i was thinking is
like if this is the thing that i'm not
particularly interested in
i probably just won't use it especially
when there are so many
guns so that feels like a good segway
also welcome back phil
to talk about um the weapon variety like
how many guns did you get to play with
did you have any favorites that you
liked because like my favorite one was
uh what are they called a cyber psycho
that i took down which is sort of like a
like it's it's set up in like a monster
hunter kind of way
where um there was someone who was
pinged on my map as having
enhanced themselves so much that they
kind of went insane
and so i had to go and take him down and
he had a a gun that could shoot through
walls
i was kind of the loot that i got from
him and i loved that like i i was
very attached to it in a way that i kind
of didn't want to use anything else so
did you guys have any
cool weapons that you used that stand
out
that was that was a similar thing for me
where i like the the gun once i got a
rifle that you could charge up the shot
and then it could also pierce walls
it was so fun to just like ping an enemy
so you could see everybody's hologram
and then just like go into a different
room and pick them off from their like
basically like wall hacks that was
really really cool would they react to
you
uh yeah once you started shooting yeah
they would react but they wouldn't
immediately know where you were right
yeah they would kind of lose you yeah
that's pretty neat yeah you can go in
and out of stealth that's a thing
like i don't know if it's super clear
from what we've seen is like
you know you can alert everybody in a
room or in a
base or whatever but if they lose track
of you they do lose track of you they'll
still be on
alert but so that you can blast
everybody and then kind of run
make a run for it get lost for a bit and
then shoot them through walls
um that's always a good time i also had
a sniper rifle that um
could seek like over cover though
no that's pretty excellent i used that
pretty absolutely
yeah yeah i know i got the shotgun that
was like a taser
nice that was like just a very
satisfying sound of this
electric pulse that was really fun um so
i guess
i would like to know if you guys chose
different paths what did you both start
with
uh i went corpo oh really yeah
i am very interested in corporate
because i i took uh the street kid
gotcha you know it's it's fairly you
know anti-corporate and
pretty divorced from the corporate path
um so i'm really interested to hear what
corporate's like
well i don't even know how to ask you
guys questions that would help
differentiate the two paths i guess
like tom what were the like corporate
things that you did well that was the
that's
the thing that kind of caught me like
surprised me a little bit is that the
life path seemed
like it seems like it significantly
changes kind of dialogue options you
have
but i was surprised to see that
basically it's like a
half hour intro and then there's like a
montage to get you
on to the same page as every other life
path and like
from there it's basically just dialogue
like i was kind of expecting more
of a of a difference at the beginning of
the game but
that said like every time i had to talk
to someone who was wearing a suit
basically like every time there was
someone higher up
i could had a little corpo thing that
was made that conversation
way easier and then on top of that and
i'll avoid spoilers here but
it also made me like a a dick in a lot
of ways that i didn't want to be when i
was talking to like
uh when i was trying to like service
people basically so like anybody that
was like
high class or really low class like i
could
be a lot smoother with and so like there
was this one time where i was trying to
get into a hotel and i'll avoid spoilers
but i was trying to get into a hotel
and you're talking to this front desk
person and they do something you don't
want to do and you have this corporate
option that's just like
did i ask you to do that and you're not
like
really mean to them but that's also kind
of like
in line with what you would be if you
were like a corpo guy
in that world so it like it it was cool
in that way it just didn't feel like
overly significant outside of those
dialogue choices i guess but those
dialogue choices were pretty impactful
yeah it seems like it's mostly dialogue
um from what i can tell
the it gives you different insights into
different situations when you're talking
about people and it like highlights it
and it kind of
also appears when you know you don't
have that option to kind of give you
a sense of like what you're missing to
so you can kind of go back maybe
which is cool like i i like the street
kid path is
feels pretty much in line with what you
end up doing
later you know when it once it
streamlines the story back to where kind
of everybody
is going street kid is pretty much like
from down the street of that if that
makes sense yeah i played
the street kid intro in the four hours
that i played
so i'm guessing what happens is that at
the point where
there's there was supposed to be a cut
scene for me which i think is what
you're referring to tom they didn't have
the cutscene at the time
um and then i think you that's after the
car thing was
for street kid uh we were trying to
steal the car and then you would you
would wake up on the street and that
would be when everyone is at the same
spot
and i know what the through line is
after that and that's where like you
know
the johnny silverhand stuff comes in i
guess did you guys have him i don't know
what point that shows up and i don't
want to get into spoilers but
it's pretty deep in uh there's oh okay
it's quite there's quite a bit of story
um before you get there well i guess
it's it's not a
huge amount so you've got the the um
steal the car
scenario that you mentioned and then you
kind of get thrown in with
um other characters that we've seen in
the trailers
and stuff uh who are like your crew and
then you start
putting together a job with them after
the montage scene
and that job takes a while to get
together but that
is relates to the biochip thing that has
johnny in it yeah
so that's what i figured it takes
you know it's first probably six hours
or so
yeah it took me about six hours to get
to that point too it's a slow burn like
that's like
i think you know you were talking about
it with the comparison to gta
uh earlier and like it really does like
one thing i saw a lot of people happy
about was that it to me it like really
felt like an rpg
right like it does not feel like first
person shooting whatever it
does not feel like an action game really
it has the pace of something like the
witcher
and that you're going to be having a lot
of conversations you can go long periods
of just like
doing talking quests and not really
getting into fights if you don't really
want to
and like i really enjoyed that but it's
very different i think than a lot of the
marketing might make it look
right and even the combat to me feels
like real deliberate
yeah it's not like a run and gun action
game you can't play it that way but it's
hard
to do that like every time i tried to
run and gun and you know
blast through six or eight guys they
pretty much kick my ass
enemies enemies deal a lot of damage and
are pretty bullet spongy in my
experience and so
like yeah if you just run out and start
firing it's really not
like it's not the best way to do things
and it's not the most amusing way to do
things especially when this game
gives you so many tools it's the whole
thing you don't have to
right exactly exactly you know the more
the gang
for sure that that uh that quest i've
spoken about this
on my channel a bunch but i don't know
that i've spoken to either of you two
about it
i got through without any combat yeah
right um
because i managed to basically get some
intel
that meant that i got the uh corpos who
were there
actually sorry it was um uh it's what it
medtech i think is is the
miltek um and the
maelstrom gang to fight each other so i
didn't have to fight any of them
so the boss fight that is set up there
for you um i was watching
but didn't have any input in um which is
so cool because like that's the thing
that i always really liked about the
which even going back to the witcher 2
if i'm being honest i love the witcher 2
is that you could kind of talk your way
out of any boss fight you could convince
people that they were ethically wrong
and prevent a fight which like you can
still do in this game which i
i absolutely love it for but i guess uh
to circle back to what you guys are
talking about here where
we're sort of into combat so i know i've
spoken about different parts like what
weapons you like how you felt about
hand-to-hand combat but uh how do you
feel
about the combat overall like and how
in-depth you can get with customizing
your builds and how how differently you
can approach things
i didn't get too deep into customization
like i kind of was
burning through story um and i
i want to spend more time on that
because like there were a lot of areas
where i felt lacking
especially early on like you're you have
a hard time i thought
um once i started to get cooler guns it
loosened up a little bit but there was a
while there that i was
uh struggling a little bit honestly like
you have to be smart and deliberate
about
your choices and how you want to
approach different fights
um i i enjoyed it a lot but i like i
said i got my ass kicked quite a bit
as i was kind of learning the ropes yeah
i
i agree that the early on i was pretty
underwhelmed with the combat like pretty
like this is okay and i was enjoying it
still also
but like i was just not like blown away
by it and as
i kind of dug more in got more options
got cooler guns like that one that could
shoot through walls like
that's when it started becoming way more
interesting to me and
opening up a lot more and i think that
this is
a long long game like i i don't know
about you i didn't get deep into any of
the skill trees really
not really didn't really get into the
cyber augment stuff because there's just
a long
there's a high ceiling on all that stuff
right like you can
you can be playing and upgrading and
unlocking for a long time in this game
it feels like until you're
really and i i think it takes it took me
like
probably 10 to 12 hours of playing
before i got some stuff that felt like
oh i'm doing some cooler things now
where like i got a cyber augment that
when i was aiming when i dodged while
aiming down sights time would slow down
and like once i got that fights were way
more fun
right it was really cool to have that
ability
in a way that like just literally didn't
exist before i had it and like even like
the fancy arms like the mantis blades
and stuff like that
those i think don't even unlock until
like street cred level 25 or something
like that
like it takes you a while to get to that
stuff
yeah it checks out i i know that
contextually you're supposed to be a
beginner at the start you're not
supposed to have like combat experience
right
um and they they definitely lead into
that and i feel like that probably is
the only way that they can really get
you
into uh a super deep rpg
system is by having you just start
completely blank slate
yeah and and so like not that it's a
complaint either because like i was
still enjoying the game
it's just like i i think it's gonna take
longer than 16 hours to really kind of
understand
how deep or shallow that that well is in
terms of
makes me feel so much pressure because
i'm like making like there are rpgs
where i make decisions at the start that
i regret 20 hours in yeah
well we're gonna be able to respect like
what happens here it's super stressful
um respect i don't know
but the one thing i can't remember one
thing i did like was that uh
the perks that you use level up
independently of the skill points in
them
right so like if you put all your stuff
into stealth and then you realize man i
really hate stealth
i just want to go melee or i just want
to go you know all shotguns
using shotguns will level up the perk
that gets you point like
that makes you better with shotguns
completely independently of any of the
skill point decisions you've made which
i thought was really really cool because
then
mid-game if you're just using one
strategy it's going to be more leveled
up
and that's like allows you to use it
more even though you've put your points
into it way early
or put your put your points to other
things yeah yeah
i like that it it specializes as you
specialize basically which is cool
um andrew in the chat asked this is also
a good question
um asked he said he wants to do a
pacifist run
how likely do you guys think that will
even be
by the sounds of things i'd say very
hard i think it's going to be just
yeah exactly like you can get non-lethal
weapons
and stuff and you can that's why i
assume what he means i think that they
said to me that you do have to engage in
combat but you don't have to kill people
yeah
um you can steal it i feel like it'll be
really hot stuff uh
you know you choke them out instead of
break their neck or whatever so you have
like
those options um
i imagine it'll be those options will be
pretty okay in terms of like if you just
don't want to kill anybody you can
probably
do that all right but you're still gonna
have to do combat yeah you also
have quite a bit of like hacking
capabilities and
you know so like if you wanted to do it
all a ghost run
with stealth i think it's probably
pretty viable
except for you know those few moments
where you're forced into combat
but you know if you're real careful
about it and you really spec out that
way i think you can
mostly avoid fighting most of the time
and even kind of my plan yeah even if
you do get into combat like you said
earlier you can
you can kind of bail and you know break
line of sight try to hide out for a few
minutes
and you know at least have the option to
kind of try to sneak past people again
once you've
you know once you've blown it up a
little bit
so yeah i never tried that um reese
amrios i do not know the answer to this
question what happens when you die
in game uh load your save load a
checkpoint
yeah it's just pretty standard load a
checkpoint the quick save button will be
your friend here
anybody who's played any rpg quicksave
button is gonna be your friend because
you can't save mid combat but like even
in like long encounters where you're
like going through different floors or
different rooms
you can save between fights and you're
probably going to want to because
because like phil said there are some
hard encounters in this game especially
early on when you're getting your
footing
noted um it was another question here
but there are a lot of questions
i'll do what i can people so i guess
someone else do you think that the
public will be disappointed
uh when the game comes out and i feel
like that's like a thing that i've seen
people talk about a million times that
is so subjective and impossible to
answer is like are people gonna be
disappointed i don't know you so i can't
tell you if i can
be disappointed i mean exactly the the
thing i'll say about that
is you remember the first week that the
witcher 3 came out all the internet was
talking about was how the graphics had
been downgraded
and like now years later like nobody is
complaining
about the witcher 3 being an ugly game
so like
i don't know yeah i think it'll be fine
um
yeah i mean i feel like it is really
hard to say um yeah oh yeah we spoke
about so
you guys did play with uh with johnny
silverhand you did have
him how how was he did you like him was
it was it annoying
uh what was it like hanging out with
that guy for a long time it's not
annoying because he's not
around all the time he pops up at
specific moments to like
interact with the story cutscene or give
his two cents about a conversation
you're having
you know he's basically cortana he's
what i keep for tyler
yeah he's not always there uh he's not
always there
he's kind of a dick but that's sort of
the point
um you have a bit of an antagonistic
relationship with him which is
interesting
yeah and you know you kind of tune that
over time based on how you interact with
him or
how you feel about him yeah and that's i
don't know i thought
no i just like i liked having him around
i like piano
it was it's kind of cool uh that that
also factors in i think you're
you're i agree with all that and like
the other part of it is that the way
quests work in this game where
conversations work in this game a lot of
the time you just like walk up to people
and they start talking
right like you're not like you don't
press a button to engage and silverhand
works really nicely into that
that set of setup because you can just
be like one point i was watching through
kind of like
or walking through like kind of like a
market bazaar area and there was just
like a dude sitting there playing guitar
and then silverhand just like showed up
next to him and started talking about
the songs he was playing and music
and then that triggered a quest right
right and like that was that that's a
very like natural extension of that and
makes him feel
like phil said not like annoying or
anything but he just pops up and adds a
lot of flavor occasionally
i am going to say something a little sad
which is i think keanu is not a great
voice actor i've always
thought that he's a fine actor very
lovable man
i played as a male v and v was like i
thought his voice was actually like
really good like the voice acting in
this game i think is really good across
the board and keanu is
maybe the weak link in that uh not that
he's terrible right or anything but like
it's just like he's he's he's good it is
also hard to disconnect
uh when you're so used to it being keanu
reeves i do think we have trouble with
that that we're like oh this is keanu
reeves
yeah so he doesn't have that much of a
chance uh ultimately but i i feel like i
agree with that in any case but i still
think i mean he's uh
i feel like he's a good choice for the
for the character he's got he's got the
swagger for it
yeah yeah no he's good i mean but he's
also playing
keanu as you have seen him in every
cyberpunk movie that he's been in so
like
you know that's in every thousand john's
he's been exactly
expected to expect piano basically like
you know it's the same
but like you said a little i like he's
fine a little more of a jerk keanu
yeah yeah yeah we haven't seen much of
that um but you did just mention being
in a bizarre
type of place tom and i know i've spoken
about this a bit too but i don't know
how much it's changed obviously they're
still actively working on development
um how populated did you guys feel the
world was
uh because i had a couple of issues with
npcs
being repeated even right next to each
other like they'd be sitting on a table
and executing the same animation at the
exact same time type stuff i mean it's a
video game that stuff happens but yeah
how did you feel about
the population of the open world i
didn't see anything like that i felt
like it was pretty dense
actually there are a few points where i
was like trying to get somewhere
and like running down the street
elbowing people out of the way
everybody's yelling at me like because
it was
that many people around right like i
could not i couldn't get through crowds
very easily a lot of the time yeah um
my experience was that there was like
occasionally some pop in
and like other weird like it's still
being polished and i imagine it'll
probably be polished
a little into um post release as well
um so you know there were a little there
were a few like little
bits of weirdness around there but for
the most part it felt good like it feels
like a city i thought a lot of people
doing a lot of things talking
a lot of like little events happening
around you um
sort of in that miles or that spider-man
kind of sense with like crimes and
things people interacting with stuff so
um
yeah i thought it was cool i don't know
what was your experience tom
no i agree uh there are definitely parts
that are less populated than others but
like
largely when you're walking around busy
areas like that the amount of people
seemed pretty impressive to me like it
was it's it's really cool
it's this is a very very unfair
comparison but
i was playing that and then i jumped
straight into
yakuza yakuza like a dragon which i'm
also playing right now i'm really really
really enjoying
but like and obviously yakuza is not
trying to do what cyberpunk is trying to
do right they're very very different
games doing very very different things
but like walking around night city and
then walking around
each and joe like that it's like it made
each ninja feel
so flat right like really really flat
and i like that world a lot i like
running around it i'm really enjoying
that game but like
yeah the scope of this
game location is kind of like nothing
i've really
seen in a game city before it really
really is impressive
i felt like the um diversity of the
population and obviously even saying the
word diversity triggers some people
they're like
but i just mean like the way that that
people are dressed
like how colorful some of them are how
vastly different the styles are
and we saw that in one of the recent
night city wires but
um walking around and seeing you know
npcs that just look
vastly mismatched and totally different
was really cool to me because i feel
like even in
a gta or a yakuza people
look like they think the average person
dresses in that location
whereas i feel like cyberpunk doesn't
have an average there are
people wearing ridiculous stuff with
ridiculous hairstyles all across the
board but i only saw like the
i don't even know what part of the city
i was in but i wanted to ask like do you
feel like the styles
change or the kinds of people that you
see change depending on what part of the
city that you're in
oh yeah definitely okay um yeah totally
i went pretty deep into the story and
it eventually takes you through several
different districts and
several different areas and even outside
of the city as well into like the sort
of
la style desert around the outside and
yeah there are a lot of different
populations with a lot of different
styles and like um some areas are
are poorer than others is you know like
pacifica
we've seen in the trailers is like kind
of just super run down and abandoned by
the rest of the
corporations and stuff so you really get
like a sense of
um how people are living and that comes
through
their style and it's real diverse like
you said but at the same time it's
it's keyed in a different way and then
you know that nomad people out
in the uh desert a little more mad
maxish um
you know and like jeans and leather
jackets and that sort of thing so it was
cool like it's i think it
does a good job of feeling like all
these places are distinct and the people
who live there are distinct
within that sort of like yeah but
everybody has their own style too
sweet i love that um we've also had a
lot of questions and i am kind of
curious if
you guys are even able to really get
into this stuff uh
people keep asking about romance options
like i know what some of them are
i know judy i know meredith i think
those are the other two that i actually
know of but um meredith is supposed to
be really difficult to
romance did you guys get into any of the
romance because we've not seen any of
that
uh yeah i messed with this i actually
wrote a whole uh
oh yeah i've got a great headline about
this thank you uh
well how is it how does it work i guess
so i didn't
know what i was going to say is what you
did romance
no exactly so i didn't get far enough
into any of the stories with the
characters
to do romance with the characters um
these the sense that i get is that like
it's a lot of going through side quests
and helping people out and like picking
dialogue options that
endear them to you and like putting in
your time with them
to get to that point i don't really know
what that's like
but i did um pick up a sex worker
at one point while the devs and the pr
people were watching they pointed it out
to me
and i was like now we ha now i have to
you like showed me and people are going
to want to know about this so yeah
and you know it's pretty standard um
if you've seen sex scenes in the witcher
3 it's not
too far removed from that maybe a little
more graphic but it's not like a
bouncing call
no it's a little more than that it
doesn't work
yeah it's first person it doesn't like
give you stat boosts or anything
and there's no male nudity i feel like
people have been asking me about that
um but oh interesting even if you play
as male
v there is a male like you can like
there's very much male nudity in the
character creator right
i didn't mess with that part so that was
too
awkward for me with everybody watching
my screen i was like yeah
i had that when i was playing in two
that i was like i felt weird about the
certain things that i was paying
attention to because you know that
somebody with that kid at home in poland
is watching you play every part of it
yeah can i can i uh i'll tell this story
so um i was kind of
largely because it was a pr person and a
developer
watching every move i made avoiding
trying like sex worker stuff because i
just like
the awkwardness was gonna kill me it's
so awkward though yeah
um but i uh i did a quest at one point
where i got this person who asked me to
meet me
me meet them at a place and i thought it
was just picking up a quest
and i want no spoilers or anything and i
thought it was just meeting a quest
giver
and they had me at the second i opened
this door
to like a hotel room uh it's just
them mostly naked on the bed and it
launches into an unskippable
sex scene that i did not know i was
going into and i was like
no no no no no like it was just
and then it rewarded me with a weapon a
melee weapon that's a dildo with a ham
like a handle as a bat so like you got a
free weapon for having sex
that's the best the funny thing is
though like you actually did have to
like
make some interesting choices to get
even get that dialogue option so like
there might be some people who are going
to
miss that entirely if they didn't if
they did a different life path or did
different things in a certain situation
but basically you guys did not actually
go down a romance path with
any of the characters no the vibe i got
was that that stuff's
later game you yeah yeah they also would
not
talk to me about it i asked cd projekt
pretty point blank and they were like we
don't want to talk about it we don't
want to spoil it
so like you've said more about it just
now than
i have heard really interesting so yeah
i'm very curious how it works because
like have either of you played dragon's
dogma
no i know i absolutely love that game
and highly recommend it um
but basically like at one of the endings
of that game
whoever your romance option is just kind
of shows up
and will be there for you and it's
actually just the person that you've
given the most stuff to
so and you could not know that you'll be
like you
because it's like maybe you were bribing
a shopkeeper to give you lower rates so
you gave them a bunch of [ __ ] and then
they show up at the end of the game like
ready to get married and you're like
well [ __ ]
you didn't mean to do that so i'm hoping
it's a little bit more expensive than
that but i guess we'll see
i don't know how long this game is going
to be i know there was the headline of
the dev playing for like 175 hours or
something
but they also said they also said that
they saw criticisms that the witcher 3's
main quest line was too long and they
wanted to at least make the main quest
line
shorter they said that in an interview
with me i did that
interview yeah apparently people
complained that that was too long but
that doesn't mean that the game outside
of the main quest line is too long but i
mean if you guys played for 16 hours and
at least phil it sounds like you
definitely did focus on
the main story yeah i got pretty deep um
i think i was approaching like
two-thirds
three-quarters around that yeah i'm okay
with that like i'm cool with that
it's you know the 30-hour story and then
everything else
that's also a guess i don't actually
know official but that was kind of the
impression i was getting
yeah how did you guys feel about some of
the side quests that you did were there
any
cool interesting things in there phil
did you do side quests or did you just i
did a little
i know yeah i was like i really want to
run off and do side quests
but there's a lot of stuff with johnny
silverhand right now and i'm really
interested
so um i i did kind of like dip off and
do a couple
um i did some judy quests and
i just started one that was a you're
like investigating what happened to the
mayor of night city who was murdered
and there's a whole like investigation
you meet up with a detective
and um everybody's trying to kind of
figure out who's
who's behind that and it definitely
comes off as a sort of political
um hit maybe there's weirdness there i
know when i started
specifically and i think it would only
happen for street kids they were talking
about there being an election coming up
in night city
is that a thing that plays under the
story at all i don't
know if it's more than that side quest
but although i the impression i got was
that
i was the beginning of an arc there and
i think it's related to that
detective character i think his name is
river i didn't spend that much time with
him but the
the des did mention that like there's a
lot going on with him and that's
kind of the impression i get of a lot of
this is that
you might pick up a side quest and it's
sort of
you know feels like a one-off like hey
here's a job but then you interact with
some people
in the course of doing that job and then
they have more stuff to do
and you kind of build um relationships
with them
and character arcs with them and that
kind of drives these little side stories
so they become more than just like
one-off
missions pretty fast that was the
impression i got gotcha
and it's it's funny because counter to
what you did i
blazed through the prologue pretty much
as fast as i could
uh that first day and then the second
day i basically split 50 50 between
doing
main story missions which i agree were
like super compelling to me and so i
wanted to be doing them but then also i
was just like
there were there was a good hour or two
where i was literally just like driving
around looking for troubles
like i was just trying to like absorb
that world and
you know it was really cool to just like
drive around and see kind of like
little fighting encounters there were
some funny side missions there was one
really really like i'm trying to avoid
spoilers here
there's a really touching side mission
where uh you're essentially going to a
funeral i won't say anything more than
that but like it's
really deep like it's like like you and
you can kind of like choose kind of how
how much you want to you get as much out
of that as you give basically time wise
and like it was really touching right
like there was some cool stuff like that
and then there was a whole nother side
mission questline multi-part quest where
um you're tracking down there's this ai
cab company called dellamane
and you're tracking down rogue delamane
taxis that have like
gone haywire and off the grid around the
town and around the city
and every one of them or most of them
are in different neighborhoods so
they're way spread out and every single
one of them is basically like this
little like
mini joke encounter for you to see
that's just like very goofy um and
very referential to other things uh and
yeah it like those those i was really
nice to see that there was
like both levity and kind of like
serious just like
talking about your feelings moments in
this like really bombastic game
i feel like the witcher does that too
there's like totally ridiculous stuff
and some really heartfelt stuff but
yeah i feel like my impression is that
tonally cyberpunk is mostly dark
but then my impression does throw some
ridiculous [ __ ] at you as well
it's probably the most like this is very
silly but like the most adult game
i have ever played right like there's
sex and violence absolutely everywhere
on a scale of
i haven't really seen kind of like this
much in a game and that's not what again
yeah it totally fits the world it
doesn't
at least in the 16 hours i played didn't
feel like over the top or
unnecessary in a lot of times except for
maybe the fact that there are at least
four different collectible types of
dildos
scattered around the world for no reason
but beyond that
like it it just felt like a very sort of
like they know the audience they're
targeting for this game
and it is definitely m for mature
yeah um it's real dark like a lot of the
story a lot of stuff that i encountered
um has to do with like sex trafficking
and
like other intense and tragic uh
subjects you know like a lot of a lot of
bad things happen to a lot of people in
this game
so i feel like that checks out i don't
think anyone's going to be surprised
still misled by
yeah no um i've lost the name now but
someone was asking
and i'm not sure if you guys will be
able to answer because again it seems
like this game is very deep
um if you with like cybernetic
enhancements or cyber enhancements were
able to
change your appearance dramatically like
do you know if you can
mouse trim yourself out can you change
your face completely by
upgrading things or does it seem like v
is not going to be able to go down that
path
i didn't get uh there but i'm also
not so i'm not really sure but the
impression that i get is that
um a lot of investment in like side
stuff in this game leads to interesting
uh
customizations or weapons and stuff like
that so like you get a lot out of
going off the beaten path and doing
stuff that will lead you
in that direction and you know i like
left the door open with maelstrom so i
assume that
there was more to do with them in
particular
that might go that way so yeah i don't
know for sure
but there's a lot going on in this game
like i feel like i barely skimmed it
yeah i don't remember seeing anything
specifically like that either
but well i think that would surprise me
if it is in there cdpr did say that you
can't go like
full maelstrom because you can't join
the gangs but
um i just don't know how much your
upgrades actually change
the way that you look yeah i don't i
don't know specifically in that regard
but you can do some kind of
even just right away in the character
customization you can put a lot of metal
in your face
you can make like you can make your
eyeballs like your irises look like
hearts or like skull and crossbones
from the get-go right um so there's
there's some cosmetic options to make
you look
pretty augmented up right away and i
imagine
there are probably more sort of like you
can eventually find
later in in that way i just don't know
if they're tied specifically to
like cyberware gameplay augments i do
think you can also
find places to change your appearance at
least in some ways
like um i like your nails i had
crazy nails for some reason and uh
like stuff like that so um i would
expect i would expect
at least some stuff in that direction
well this is a big talking point because
obviously it's
entirely first person uh how often did
you guys see yourselves
make sure you're happy with your
fingernails yeah
[Laughter]
that's a good point i said that as a
joke to someone at ign and then i was
like actually you know what it's just
kind of true
you'll see yourself you'll see yourself
in your inventory you'll see yourself if
you
actively turn a mirror on because all
the mirrors are like blacked over to
start
exploring mirrors or if you have ray
tracing on i guess um and look in a
puddle
but like and you'll see yourself if
you're driving in third person
but basically that's it and basically
what you'll see
most of your character is your hands so
be happy with your fingernails i've
never never thought about it before i
see my own hands a lot and my
fingernails suck so
uh noted
um i don't know why this question's
coming up a lot but it is coming up a
lot um
is there gambling at all
i don't know i think i didn't i don't
think i
encountered any yeah i don't think if
there were any like
games like that yeah did you see any
minigames any like
i guess there would be rockstar style
minigames obviously there's the fighting
ring thing which
like is more akin to a side pop like a
fable
fighting and those those felt like
tailored right like there's some
like the the people at those fighting
rings are like characters with
with dialogue and they're they're not
just like maybe that opens up after but
they're not just like
here's fighting generic random person
did you drop by the
um the shooting range in the apartment
building yeah i did
is that a thing i did a mission for that
um
so there is a side mission where at one
point the owner of that shooting range
will do a shooting competition
and if you win you get a reward through
it um but i don't
think i don't remember if there was like
actually like shoot it for points if you
want to do that there might have been
um gambling specifically i don't
remember yeah i mean either
i feel like the market in pacifica
uh might have had like midway style
stuff
there but i don't remember super well
when you're in a lot of shops
yeah when you're playing for only 16
hours in a world that dense you're that
kind of you're just going for other
stuff yeah you don't want to see
everything printing
yeah yeah it could be hidden somewhere
but i'm not sure i love that though that
was the thing that i had the first time
i played it people asked me questions
and i had
more often than almost any other game
i'd played my answer would be like i
actually don't know
yeah i don't know if that exists it
absolutely could it's not a no that's
clearly not here you're like i don't
know what they've done
they can't entertain anything um there
are a lot of people asking about photo
mode
i don't know anything about it does it
exist did you play with it i didn't mess
with it
if it does exist i can't yeah i don't
know either um
that this is a question that i love
because i love doing this stuff
uh is there any
property market like buying renting
properties at all
uh not that i saw but i think that cyber
or cd project specifically said there's
not
okay um elsewhere and i believe that
they are saying they're thinking about
it for like
post-launch dlc stuff because it is a
well-requested feature
but specifically i think they've gone on
record saying you're not gonna you have
these apartment and that's your house
yeah you do have an apartment and it
does seem like
uh you can buy cars and yes
keep different rides so yeah every god
constantly fixers were like hey you want
to buy a car and i was like can you just
leave me alone i'm trying to go to the
place
[Laughter]
and they're expensive too the cars are
pricey
uh yeah apparently someone in the chat
is also saying that they said photo mode
would come later
um and there are a lot of questions here
that uh i'm just not answering because
like i've answered them even a million
times on this channel or most people
know the answer to but i guess this is a
thing that you guys can most objectively
speak to
um which i know everyone's spoken about
a lot is uh how many buildings
can you go inside like on the street
like did you feel like you could
actually enter a lot of buildings my
answer that and i have discussed here
before
was not a ton of them but it also didn't
really bother me because
the outdoors are so um
well decorated and even every building
that you can't go inside doesn't just
have black windows it looks like
something you can look inside sometimes
so
my answer was generally you can't go
inside every building but it didn't
bother me that i couldn't
yeah that was my impression too like it
felt like a city like you're not gonna
go
in most of the places that you pass in
any given
city right like no i don't want to go in
these buildings there's nothing there um
yeah so like it seemed
fine there are a lot of places that kind
of i think yeah like you said get away
with it by being sort of
air about it um like
in kabuki i think it was the district
where like jig jig street is and all the
the red light stuff and
all of that is kind of outside you can
go into some storefronts
and stuff which is cool yeah but it all
just feels like
it feels like a very outdoor city which
is you know it feels like la
really yeah the the one thing i will say
i totally agree with all that the the
one thing i will say is that i did find
a lot of doors
that you know there were a lot of blank
slate doors where you walk up to them
and there's nothing and then there were
a lot of doors that you would walk up to
and it would say
locked like specifically and i think
what
is cool about how many buildings there
are is this is definitely not one of
those games you can just go into any
building and every building is populated
but also like missions can potentially
send you
into a lot of buildings yeah so like
the fact that there's you know even if
there's a block
with let's say six buildings in it and
you can only actively go in one
the other five might be used at some
point
just for a quest that you haven't found
yet right right and
and that i think i think makes the city
feel
less uninteractive than
that might come off by saying oh you
can't go in every building because
you could end up in any building
potentially it's just
you don't know if you're going to until
it sends you there it's scripted it's
also
pretty seamless about it too like you go
on a mission
you end up you know in a parking lot and
then you go into that building and
it's not like you're loading through or
anything like that it's just yeah they
feel like places that you wind up
so yeah i didn't bother me i didn't even
really think about it honestly
that i couldn't go into places i didn't
i was off doing stuff
you know like yeah every time i was
going somewhere someplace
it i was inside buildings and um
like you said i can't walk into any
building that i want to in la
so yeah exactly and you but you also
don't want to right no like it feels
like it's just
it feels more realistic than that it
doesn't feel like
you're walking through you know like a
cardboard
uh like fake movie western
town yeah it's not like that so i hope
that's coming through it's like
the it doesn't feel like it's fake um
it just also doesn't feel like you would
want to go in every place it's too dense
for that
um i won't keep you guys for too much
longer but i did want to ask did you
play with brain dance as much
oh yeah how do you like bring in stuff
and how how frequently do you do it i
guess
it's fairly frequent um in the main
story
and at least a couple of side quests
have brain dance stuff going on
as well so it's not like all the time
and it also doesn't seem like you're
just gonna be like buying brain dances
and messing with them they're always
gonna have like some sort of story
component they're about quests um but
they're cool like they're interesting
it's a good change of pace where you're
like going through a scene watching
other people do stuff trying to find
evidence
uh on the ground you know it's a little
bit of a batman feel
yeah so they're not hard either right
like
they're they're they're cooler than they
are challenging for sure
like because the the timelines for the
brain dances will tell you very
specifically where
there is a thing you can find and so
like it's
but it's more fun than stuff like the
detective stuff in the witcher because
the detective stuff in the witcher was
literally just like
follow this footprints and then click
this glowing thing and that was like
very
simple whereas this is basically that
but it's in such a kind of different
weird cool presentation
that it like becomes very cool as well
it feels like they did a good job
of writing how the brain dances work and
what the brain dance scenes
are so that as you're solving them you
feel like you're learning
information that makes sense so like the
next time you go
next time it's like okay you're gonna go
to this place because now that you learn
this thing
like you've i felt like i in a way that
games don't always
do well felt like okay i get why we're
going here and who we need to talk to
and like why this is important
you know like i got information out of
doing that
uh investigation that like pinged in my
brain it didn't just
set off a new waypoint to go find
yeah that's cool yeah um so i guess
in closing i wanted to ask um tom what
is your literal favorite thing about it
like what was the thing that you liked
the most
because i feel like a lot of the
questions that i have a lot of questions
that other people have like
outside of like what is the information
uh trying to look at this game with a
critical lens because it has so much
hype
that a lot of it is like what don't we
like about it what is it not doing
perfectly it's definitely getting that
more than most games do
um so totally what do you like most
about it and and to
to that end like yeah i've said a lot of
critical things today and like
i really enjoy this game like i'm really
liking it and i'm really excited to keep
playing it and play more of it and make
different choices and all that sort of
stuff
um probably the thing i
like most about it i can't decide
between two things and
these are probably really good signs
that these are the two things i can't
decide between is just the city itself
is just so cool right it's such a
like stunning place to be in and drive
around
and i really really loved just the world
and then also
and i'm not going to talk about this
because it's spoilery the main story is
really cool
right the main story there there is a
moment in the prologue again i won't
spoil it and there's a moment in
prologue where basically like the
inciting incident happens and it hooks
you into it
and i was hooked i was watching this
like you know there aren't cut scenes
but the first-person cutscene play out
literally with my hand over my mouth
like oh oh man oh man like
i was the story of this game did a
really good job of getting me invested
and getting v invested i think and i'm
i'm really excited to see where it goes
great how about you phil uh i gotta say
that i most enjoyed the characters
um i liked hanging out with people
inside missions
and like the game does a really good job
of not just
you know putting you in a sequence where
okay you've gotta like team up with
another mercenary and they drive with
you to the place and then you shoot the
things with them
like you spend a lot of time with people
you do a lot of conversations with
people
and you build a rapport with them and
like it it feels really good
about that i really liked hanging out
with the people in this world
more than even i think i like the world
in general i think it it does a good job
of making
a lot of compelling characters spend a
lot of time with you
and you get a chance to like work on
how you want those relationships to go
even with johnny honestly um
you know like you spend a lot of time
with johnny and he's interesting as you
learn more things about him
and you don't have to like him for him
to be interesting
yeah so there's a little like a lot of
cool
nuance there that i'm that's the stuff i
want to get back to like i really want
to go
dig into those side quests so i can
spend more time with judy and
and other characters and like see what
they're
in a group
yeah i felt like i definitely got that
vibe when i played too and that there
are a lot of characters
and they are all incredibly different um
and i also like that they all have this
law surrounding them and renown
like people know who they are um and
have
this they just all have this mystique
that i think is very cool for a lot of
the
um fixers especially it's like people
know who they are and talk to you about
them and they're like oh this person did
this so like oh we know this gang
because of this and the way it feeds you
that information i think has
has to be very difficult and there's
something that i think cdpr is very good
at
is giving you a lot of law without
sitting you down and making you read a
book they really just like
tell you what this world is and how
everyone operates in this world and
who's important and why
without being like he's important look
out for him it's like a vibe
sometimes it's the way other people
react around them i feel like there are
a lot of things like that that are
particularly cool and i'm very excited
to play it um jealous that you guys got
to play it um
and i think i we could talk for forever
but i will let you guys go
um yeah there are a lot of questions in
here that were
things that have been already answered
um to the guy who kept bitching about
how this is a terrible stream because we
only answered five questions apparently
it's because so many of them are things
that have already been answered or
things we can't answer like
these people did not play on ps4 you
guys both played on pc correct
can't talk about that kind of stuff um
there are a lot of things that i've
spoken about on this channel
specifically
um so tons and tons and tons of
information and i imagine that you guys
both have
have a few articles up as well um so
that we can let people know
where to find them did you guys want to
like plug any of the stuff that you've
written if anyone wants more information
yeah um i did you know actually
basically the things we just talked
about i wrote
on gamespot you can find them uh in our
cd project or our
cyberpunk coverage we've got a ton of it
um
yeah i wrote a thing about the sex it
was
and it's i kind of didn't want to go
read that yeah
i'm curious about it what is what is the
headline again it's like dcd your cd
projekt right i'm sorry i made you watch
a sex scene or something
yeah i'm sorry i made you watch it with
me specifically
yeah because it was good it's so weird
yeah yeah kudos to our
video host lucy who came up with that
headline because i can't take credit for
it
uh how about you tom yeah i'll give a
shout out i also have a preview talking
about a lot of the similar stuff as well
as like a
we took kind of ama style questions and
did like a burning questions video
for that um and then also i'll give a
shout out to both of those you can find
on ignri
youtube.com ign and then also uh another
video that we just put out recently john
ryan
who is a one of our features editors who
i love dearly
um and is crazy into the tabletop game
cyberpunk 2020
so he did a video recently uh that's
like the story so far
basically looking at like all of the
history
of cyberpunk before this game and like
what
because 2077 is like like sequel to
the tabletop game 2020 and yeah other
stuff so like
basically he rounded up kind of some of
the lore of the world and
and put it into a nice video to talk
about to set the stage for this game
without spoiling
yeah i should say that we've also got
like a ton of deep dive lore stuff
um in video form at gamespot as well
because
our guys have been uh digging way into
it and like i watched a bunch of them
after the fact i was like oh wow this
makes a whole lot more sense there's so
much there
there's a ton it's really cool actually
just as a final point to be
a nobody in a world full of legends
right
like john everyone in this world knows
johnny silverhand everyone knows adam's
smasher
everyone knows like arakawa like all
these people and so like
it's really cool to just be like a
nobody in that world just like meeting
these legends is really well i i keep
being curious if that's gonna lost like
are you going to stay an absolute nobody
or are you going to be a legendary
i mean that's kind of your whole deal
right it's like you're trying to be
a legend you're trying to build your
street cred people start to recognize
you
but also i think um how you like choose
to go about that
might have some effect on it as well
like whether or not you are actually a
legend or just a well-known joke
you know so we'll see
all righty well thank you guys for
joining um i will
link in the description if you guys have
any stuff that you would like people to
to answer um or rather no i will
it's because i'm reading chat my brain
did not execute that sentence correctly
at all so many questions that have
already been answered i'm trying to do
my best here but it's stuff that you
guys should already know
um like this person keeps asking if
johnny silverhand is inside missions um
we said yes uh i will leave a link in
the description to anything that you
guys would like
people to read so this i'll just update
this shortly and then we can have the
links of stuff you guys have written in
there but thank you for joining me
that is tom uh tom what can people find
you on the internet
uh tom r marks on twitter and then that
is phil phil where can people find you
on the internet at phil hornshaw on
twitter
beautiful very easy you guys chose smart
names not [ __ ] charolanazad so
good job on that all right bye everyone